i use that with you can you give us an
idea what the people here
think about the suns and also your
chances of winning a championship
the fans what they think about the suns
yes
i mean i think it's the the baby here
you know it's the only
professional team that has phoenix in it
every other team's arizona so
phoenix suns is the baby franchise here
and they love it with with the passion
and
you know i'm wearing the shirt from 93
right now
i think it started around that time to
when
you know they develop that you hear
people talk about i remember when i
watched charles and them like you hear
those stories at all times and
seeing the passion in their eyes when
they're telling the stories and
even being at the bottom of the barrel
for the past five years and them still
showing up and showing love
you know shows that same type of love
that they have for this team
you have any examples of maybe the last
couple weeks when you've had
interactions
with people any stories to tell about
how excited they are
um not really i haven't been around too
many people
and i've just been in the house for real
so i've been i've been laying low